retrouver tout de suite sur place l'une
de nos équipes Cyril Payen et
georgiabeck Cyril bonjour on vous avait
tout à l'heure par téléphone vous nous
décriviez ces scènes de chaos c'est
blessé également qui qui fuyait sous le
feu de l'armée russe alors que
l'offensive russe s'accentue aujourd'hui
oui effectivement nous sommes revenus à
5 km du point où nous étions
juste aux portes en fait de cette ville
satellite du RPN il n'y a pas de signe
de signal de satellitaire pour
transmettre évidemment c'est une zone de
guerre donc on peut parfaitement le
comprendre donc nous sommes ici et bien
au dernier barrage au dernier checkpoint
avant ces 5 km qu'il faut franchir à
travers la une forêt assez dense pour
arriver au pont pont qui est maintenant
détruit et pour arriver à à IRP pin
c'est ce c'est 5 km ce n'est pas anodin
puisque c'est extrêmement dangereux il y
a énormément de coups de feu des tirs
d'artillerie de mortier que l'on entend
et qui se pressent à ma gauche comme
nous revenions nous avons entendu des
tirs dans ces bois juste là donc c'est
ça veut dire certainement que les forces
russes qui depuis irpin face au bout de
cette route sur ta environ 1500 mètres
ou deux kilomètres selon les forces en
présence ukrainiennes qui nous informe
et bien il y a des tirs qui se
rapprochent et des bombardements qui se
rapprochent de ce côté et de l'autre
côté il y a des fumées noires un peu
partout c'est ce qu'on a pu voir pendant
les trois ou quatre heures que nous
avons passé aux portes d'erpin avec
Georgias Beck donc ici c'est le dernier
point d'accès et c'est ça aussi la
réalité de ce siège qui est en train de
se former ici à Kiev et bien ce sont ces
vagues incessantes des images je dois
avouer absolument déchirantes de
familles entières avec une grand-mère un
grand-père des animaux il y a beaucoup
d'animaux domestiques qui doivent fuir
qui passe à pied cette rivière avec le
pont détruit et que l'on voit certains
sont portés ils sont exténués il y a
beaucoup de gens en larmes et ils vont
rejoindre ces bus jaune que vous pouvez
voir ici qui sont des bus justement pour
ce corridor humanitaire mais parlons
vraiment est-ce qu'on parle vraiment
d'accord une heure humanitaire quand on
a vu l'intensité des tirs de mortiers
d'artillerie et des bombardements qui on
continue tout cela laisse un peu songeur
mais des scènes réellement un
déchirantes de ces gens qui quittent une
vie on le voit bien leur routine dans
ses villes satellitaires de la capitale
ukrainienne au nord-ouest des villes
très calmes très peuplées et qui doivent
tout abandonner avec sans savoir
également évidemment quand il y aura
quand il y aura un retour il y aura-t-il
un retour et là il partent tous pour
beaucoup vers l'inconnu donc c'est une
scène extrêmement déchirante et qu'on ne
pouvait difficilement imaginer cela aux
portes de l'Europe dans des dans des en
Ukraine un pays où tout fonctionnait il
y a encore et bien moins de deux
semaines avant l'invasion russe cette
invasion russe rouleau compresseur qu'on
sent résolument et là on entend encore
des bombardements qu'on s'en résolument
arrivé sur tous les points de la
capitale pour arriver finalement à ce
qui ce qui n'est plus un secret et tout
le monde le sait pour un siège un siège
total de la capitale ukrainienne
je ne sais pas si vous avez le temps si
vous pouvez répondre à une une deuxième
question le gouverneur
ukrainien de la région de mikolaïve
indique que les forces ukrainiennes ont
repris
l'aéroport régional cette armée
ukrainienne qui résiste le président
volodiae ski a appelé à la poursuite de
cette résistance d'ailleurs ce matin
j'imagine que vous avez pu échanger avec
eux c'est ces derniers jours quelle est
leur état d'esprit aujourd'hui
le pont qui écrivait de balle et Sergueï
se bat ici depuis 6 jours pour son pays
donc il y a des volontaires il y a
énormément de force ukrainiennes qui se
massent là et on sent bien qu'on se
prépare à une bataille peut-être pas
encore une bataille de rue puisque pour
l'instant ce sont essentiellement des
tirs d'artillerie de mortier et puis des
beaucoup de bombardements mais ça se
rapproche et on voit bien qu'il y a une
mobilisation des forces ukrainiennes
très importantes qu'il faut on sent bien
qu'ici c'est vital stratégiquement de
coûte que coûte sauver cette entrée de
Kiev par le nord-ouest cette ville
d'herpin merci beaucoup Cyril Payet
merci aussi à georgiabeck derrière la
caméra merci pour ces images de la
région dire Pinel